most interesting thing about Jordan  Peterson that I found was the fact that  we both had kind of come to these same  conclusions and we had lived very  different lives he's a trained academic  studied this stuff his whole life and we  came to a lot of the same conclusions  about things and I just came to those  conclusions through living and the  experiences that I had and he came to  them through studying this stuff in a  very rigorous way made me feel good  about the fact that the things that I  had figured out were in line with things  that he had figured out and that means  maybe there's a little bit more strength  in universality to these things that I  believed which felt pretty good